bruno bartocetti
les faits se sont déroulés on a le
sentiment assez rapidement ce matin
année centre l'annnonce de cette attaque
meurtrière dont l'église notre-dame et
l'arrestation l'interpellation de
l'assaillant comment expliquez vous
cette réactivité c'est le résultat de
cette vidéo surveillance mise en place
par la mairie de nice voilà la vidéo
surveillance et tout est toujours une
qui est intéressant dans le cadre du
travail principe c'est dans le cadre d
un tj 10 hier mais il est vrai que cet
outil là nous a permis d'intervenir
rapidement sa demande bien sûr des
moyens humains
je parle des policiers et entraînés qui
ont fait preuve de vraiment de courage
et d'efficacité je pense à nos collègues
policiers municipaux et nationaux qui
sont intervenus rapidement
on voit là on a pu neutraliser cet
individu qui est bien sûr après avoir
tué trois personnes auraient pu en cuir
bien d'autres et cette efficacité autour
de la vidéosurveillance mais surtout de
l'efficacité des policiers ont permis
justement de le neutraliser
alors on a très peu d'informations à la
fois sur le profil de l'assaillant mais
aussi sur l'endroit où il se trouve à
présent il a été arrêté donc est-ce que
vous avez davantage d'informations à
nous donner
non ce que je n'ai pas beaucoup
d'éléments à vous donner sinon que cet
individu est âgé de 21 ans tirons un
fanatisés part par une mission divine
malheureusement qui est bien noir celle
de tuer et voilà ce qu'on sait c'est que
cette personne est entre la vie et la
mort est ce que est ce qu'on arrivera à
tirer quelques renseignements si on
arrive à le maintenir en vie ça c'est
encore une autre question et ça va être
le sujet bien sûr délicat parce que on
doute fort que ça va être ça va être
assez difficile de lui tirer les vers du
nez maintenant voilà je voudrais juste a
ajouté que vous savez les renseignements
thériault territoriaux en france font un
travail formidable
on a pu justement des jouets de nombreux
attentats parce qu'on a une personne
isolée qui répond pas bien sur l'a10
terrorisme et qui agit seul c'est
toujours très difficile d'anticiper
par contre on a pu on a pu neutraliser
rapidement ça c'est très important
des informations aussi au sujet de
d'éventuelles complicités est-ce que des
actions sont menées en ce moment des
perquisitions pour remonter le fil de
son terrible acte qu'il a donc mené dont
l'église notre-dame de nice façon voilà
il ya une enquête qui est en cours et on
va aller au bout de cette enquête comme
ça a été fait avec eux avec le
terroriste qui a tué sa mine pâti
récemment le 16 octobre
lalanne enquête va être menée de la même
manière pour savoir s'il allait agir
s'il agit seul aussi autour de lui il ya
des intervenants voilà pour l'histoire
où toutes les pistes vont être
exploitées pour justement aboutira
peut-être cibler d'autres d'autres
intervenants qui agissent et derrière
derrière lui pour le pousser au crime
est ce que vous savez ce qui se passe en
ce moment dans la ville de nice dans la
foulée de de cet attentat alors dans la
vidéo de 10,6 m voilà vous imaginez que
tout terrain peut-être voilà dans la
ville de nice sont aussi battus d'un
petit peu dans quel état d'esprit on
peut être c'est pas la première fois que
ni ses victimes d'attentats maintenant
oui bien sûr ces critiques
celui-ci propose une histoire c'est les
policiers sont sont malheureusement sur
malheureusement pas dire expérimentés
ils sont préparés à contrôler et à
sécuriser sur une discipline liste par
rapport à au passé on a une certaine
expérience pour obtenir c'est que c'est
la france entière qui est concerné et
nous agissons sur tout le territoire
français alors on les policiers c'est
quand même très compliqué mais une scène
il ya une situation sanitaire qui est
difficile à maintenir le principal c'est
le terrorisme qui pourront pousser bien
évidemment les attentats le confinement
les manifestations c'est assez
compétitifs pour les policiers mais nous
ne lâcherons rien nous allons être
présents sécurisé et français au maximum
et bien sûr ce sera une surveillance
accrue au niveau des édifices religieux
de religieux mais aussi des écoles mais
aussi nous policiers nous devons faire
attention parce que nous avons été aussi
victimes d'attentats terroristes
donc c'est vrai qu'il ya beaucoup de
travail et nous allons vraiment
aller jusqu'au bout pouvoir rejeter ces
ce terrorisme là sur le territoire
français le dispositif sécuritaire va
être renforcée autour des édifices
religieux autour des écoles ci est ce
que les forces de l'ordre sont assez
nombreuses notamment est ce que les
effectifs ont en tout cas est ce que les
forces de l'ordre peuvent répondre à ce
renforcement du dispositif de sécurité
alors difficilement c'est vrai que ça va
être très difficile parce que comme vous
le savez on le dit assez souvent moins
d'effectifs ou en recrutement s'est
effectué depuis de nombreuses années
depuis le début des attentats on a
commencé il a fallu aussi renforcer les
services de la dgsi des renseignements
territoriaux ont continué à recruter
dans la police nationale
pour pouvoir justement répondra de
manière très présentes y de l'est très
très très précise de ces risques
d'attentats et pour cela il faut du
temps malheureusement vous savez c'est
un peu comme une équipe et remettez le
parallèle comme les urgentistes et bien
il faut les former il faut en avoir
davantage et ça ce n'est pas un concept
toujours la même et donc on a du retard
on a perdu quand même c'était juste
avant les attentats
on a perdu 13 me de 700 postes de
policiers et gendarmes depuis charlie un
petit peu avant chardy on commence à
recruter dans la police nationale
et voilà on a pris beaucoup de retard et
on a encore beaucoup de services à
rembourser donc manqué d'effectif on
manque de moyens mais mais on sait aussi
qu'aujourd'hui l'état progresse dans ce
ca c mais est apte à mettre tout en
oeuvre pour opposition nous renforcer et
pour pouvoir travailler manière beaucoup
plus efficace
alors jean castex le premier ministre a
annoncé porter le plan vigipirate au
niveau urgence attentats partout sur le
territoire français et qu'est ce que
cela signifie concrètement ça va être ça
va être des contrôles et là alors qu'ils
arrivaient travail de la police n'ayant
aussi des gendarmes et des policiers
municipaux
mais les français doivent aussi nous
permettre de répondre pur plus
efficacement possible à ces contrôles
c'est à dire l'équivalent mais s'il
était déjà le cas on a progressé en
france c'est vraiment de nous aider à
aller au plus vite et d'accepter tout
tous les contrôles on va mettre en place
ça veut dire qu'on va être présent sur
tous les sites sensibles
lecture établissements scolaires
religieux les écoles jeanne oublie bien
sûr mais tous les services publics
aujourd'hui doit doit aussi nous
permettre de travailler efficacement ça
va être aussi des agents de sécurité
certainement de mieux pour pouvoir
repousser et prévenir le terrorisme
beaucoup d'annoncés ces derniers jours
dans la foulée de l'assassinât de samuel
pâtit ce professeur d'histoire tué à
conflans sainte honorine pour avoir
montré des caricatures de mahomet en
cours lors de lors d'un cours sur la
liberté d'expression
beaucoup dénoncent de la part du
gouvernement du ministre de l'intérieur
de la justice
le chef du gouvernement jean castex
emmanuel macron ont donné sept ont cette
image ont renvoyé cette image d'un
certain volontarisme pour lutter contre
le terrorisme alors ça passe aussi par
une lutte contre la haine en ligne est
ce que vous avez ressenti les effets de
ces déclarations dans votre façon de
travailler d'une façon ou d'une autre
voilà écoutez on a on a quand même le
sentiment que que voilà que le que le
nôtre ministre l'intérieur et il
explique nous donne à l'envi effet nous
donne les ont envie de nous donner les
moyens de travailler mais mais l'a pour
l'instant ce sont des propos qui ont été
tenus
on attend les actes des actes ça va
passer par un recrutement d'effectifs
que je le dis avec beaucoup de moyens
aussi sur une la chaîne pénale ou aussi
on attend beaucoup et ce à travers ce
pédalo ce qu'on a à faire
en face de nous un voyou ou un criminel
là aussi on doit donner des moyens à la
justice pour travailler il est hors de
question de creuser un fossé entre la
justice et la police des moyens de les
donner à la justice
également à la police pour permettre de
reposer le terrorisme mais pour essayer
de répondre à votre question
effectivement sur le terrain on a bien
le sentiment aujourd'hui il ya une prise
sérieuse de la situation pas
qu'aujourd'hui je vais pas je vais pas
non plus faire le procès de du ministère
précédent et on travaille dans ce sens
maintenant ça va très très vite et et on
demande beaucoup aux renseignements
territoriaux demande beaucoup à la dg
ici et c'est vrai que c'est assez
difficile
retenez quand même et c'est pas pour
être positif surtout aujourd'hui avec un
attentat supplémentaires à déplorer avec
un 3 3 victimes
retenez que la france des policiers
arrivent à des chenilles de nombreux
attentats alors c'est inquiétant ce que
je dirai même temps doit on doit obtenir
que notre travail nous le faisons et que
nous sommes soutenus par notre ministre
fort heureusement sur la aujourd'hui le
travail en commun entre les policiers
qui sont sur le terrain et les services
de renseignement aujourd'hui ces deux
services travaillent de concert en
harmonie on a beaucoup pointé du doigt
il n'y a pas si longtemps que ça
le l'absence des changes entre entre les
uns et les autres
oui parce qu'on va on va retenir une
fois main code de l'information sur un
service à un autre mais globalement vous
savez ce sont les policiers qui ont
passé le même concours et qui ont une
envie c'est de sécuriser bien sûr nos
citoyens et notre pays donc les
informations on est en effet remonté
elles sont nombreuses banques c c'est
compliqué aussi pour les renseignements
territoriaux de faire le tri entre les
informations pertinentes et celles qui
ne le sont pas le la coordination du
travail la coordination du travail entre
les services se fait néanmoins voilà
assez il ya une progression aussi de la
part des policiers municipaux 1
vous savez la formation plus sérieuse
ils sont ici ils sont quand même exposés
eux aussi font de leur mieux pour donner
les bons renseignements a pris tout
faire le tri c'est là où ça devient
compliqué ce n'est pas vraiment un
problème de coordination entre les
services mais est surtout un volume de
recherche très très très important et
c'est toujours très très difficile de
justement de cibler les priorités
lorsqu'on doit pas ce qu'on doit
affirmer et cibler un individu d'un
jaune
les priorités affichées par l'exécutif
il ya la lutte contre la haine en ligne
ses discours haineux qui circule
facilement sur les réseaux sociaux
c'est ce combat contre cet état de fait
ce que ça vous semble anecdotique ou
c'est capital aujourd'hui
non c'est très difficile il faut il faut
tout les toutes les informations toutes
les situations tout tout ce qui peut
être véhiculés sur les réseaux sociaux
retiennent notre attention maintenant
voyez lorsqu'on parle de fiches s il
faut savoir qu'à plusieurs richesses
est-ce que là je ne sais pas le voisin
qui m'a expliqué que le propriétaire et
où l' inverse et est un pseudo
terroriste est ce qu'on va mobiliser
trois policiers autour de cette personne
oui nous allons tenter de le faire mais
il faut vraiment faire le tri entre les
tordus les malades mentaux qui aimait
surtout les jeunes irresponsables qui
tiennent des propos intolérables sur les
réseaux sociaux et ceux qui qui
véhiculent une semaine cela bien sûr
voilà la salle parce que je pense qu'on
a quelqu'un sur les réseaux sociaux il
veut des véhicules une haine et qui
appelle qui peut être qu'apple au crime
ils se limitent pas une seule phrase
donc cela on doit les on doit vite les
cibler et c'est un regroupement et c'est
un travail important mais nous faisons
aussi la part des choses entre celui qui
peut être inconscient pas tenir une fois
bien tenir un sujet avec nautique mais
grave et ceux qui véhiculent une semaine
régulièrement sur les réseaux sociaux
c'est très difficile pour nous mais
toutes les pistes sont exploitées
oui nous prend merci beaucoup d'avoir
pris le temps de réagir sur notre
antenne brut noah bartocetti